House Republicans are at
what is supposed to be a policy retreat
right now in Florida.
But yet again, under a Trump cloud,
the event was meant to deliver
focus
on delivering on their policy promises.
Now, though,
more and more Republicans at that meeting
responding to the former president's
claims that he believes
he's about to be indicted this morning.
Jim Jordan,
who is the chairman
of the Judiciary Committee,
going on conservative TV
to say he's
asking the Manhattan
district attorney
to testify
behind closed doors to his committee,
that after Kevin McCarthy, the House
speaker, vowed
Republicans would go on offense
for Trump.
Our great reporters
are back to the table.
And so let's listen to Jim Jordan again.
Donald Trump
says he expects to be indicted
and arrested this week.
We don't know if that's going to happen.
We're waiting.
But already
Jim Jordan says
to the Manhattan district attorney,
I want to talk to you
behind closed doors for an interview
President Trump announced
he was going to run for president again.
And suddenly, here they go.
Now they're coming after him
for some alleged bookkeeping error.
You've got to be kidding me.
So we want to know
what kind of federal involvement
may have may have taken place.
It's the last part.
Jordan's a master at this.
What is is a New York
Manhattan local prosecutor?
We want to know
what kind of federal involvement
may have taken place.
Is there any evidence
of federal involvement here?
Well, that was my initial question
when I saw the letter,
because obviously Congress
generally has jurisdiction
over federal issues, federal matters.
But this Manhattan D.A.
is a state official
at the local official.
So, you know, Jordan's
kind of putting out this wink, wink,
nudge nudge thing out in the ether.
But broadly
speaking, it's
just it's really remarkable
how House Republicans
are really using the levers of government
that they have to defend Trump as as
as the president may or may not face
this indictment this week.
And I think that
perhaps Speaker McCarthy feels
he has no other choice.
We saw how reliant he is
on that Trump flank
to keep his speakership.
But it really is a new level
what is going on here.
And that's what makes it so interesting.
If you're Jim
Jordan, you've
got a very reliably Republican district.
So this is safe for you, right?
Standing up for Donald
Trump is actually good for you.
Back home.
Kevin McCarthy, as you know
it, is dependent on that
right flank
that made him speaker, including
Marjorie Taylor Greene.
We'll get to her in a minute.
But interestingly,
Kevin McCarthy
says we want to investigate
the investigator.
We will use our power to look into
what's happening here.
But he didn't make one distinction
from Trump.
Trump, in one of his posts
over the weekend
said he wanted his supporters to protest.
Kevin McCarthy says, please don't.
I don't think
people should protest this now.
And I think President Trump,
if you talk to him,
he doesn't believe that either.
We want calmness out there.
Nobody
nobody
for violence or harm to anything else.
And that is a key distinction borne of
memories of January 6th
Not no matter how much House Republicans
want to whitewash it.
And the idea that if it gets violent
or protests, that might hurt the party.
Yes.
I mean, that
that exactly is borne
out of the memory of January six.
We saw what happened there as Trump
fanned the flames
and many of his allies said,
and here we have Republicans saying
pump the brakes a little bit.
We have eight, 18 or so House Republicans
who are in districts won by Biden.
Right.
Where that kind of rhetoric, that kind of
fire fiery rhetoric doesn't
necessarily play as well as voters there.
And so, you know,
this is the kind of tricky line
Republicans are going to have
to walk on this.
And Marjorie Taylor Greene, again, key
to Kevin McCarthy speakership.
She was asked over the weekend
People were saying,
you know, Trump
didn't say peaceful protest.
He said protests.
And she said, of course,
he meant that Americans
have the right to assemble
and the right to protest.
Trump doesn't have to say peaceful
for him to mean peaceful.
Of course he means peaceful
She's not opposed to protests.
No, she's not.
And I mean,
for Marjorie Taylor Greene,
she's one of the staunchest Trump
Trump allies in the House
and she's going to
she's defending him
and defending the right to protest
and defending his calls to protest.
I just find it
so interesting that House members,
that wink
sung members
talking about it
because it's that wink of,
you know,
looking into the weaponization
of the federal government,
but in the process
weaponizing the federal government
to defend former President Trump,
people like Marjorie
Taylor Greene
are all for that,
but also all for Trump's calls
for whatever happens in the streets,
of course,
but given themselves
plausible deniability
should anything become violent.
If the House Republicans
proceed with this,
they sent the letters to Alvin Bragg.
We'll see how the case plays out.
We'll see how the Congress plays out.
Hakeem Jeffries,
the Democratic leader, says
Democrats will participate
and push back
as aggressively as possible.
But listen here.
This is Mark Kelly,
Democratic senator from Arizona,
just reelected.
So he's got a six year term
not a lot to worry about
in the short term.
He says this is dangerous for the
Manhattan prosecutor.
I would hope that if
they brought charges
that they have a strong case
because this is, as you said,
it's unprecedented.
And, you know,
there are certainly risks involved here.
But again, nobody in our nation is
or should be above the law.
Very careful there.
Nobody is above the law.
Very clear about that.
But a guy, a Democrat
from a purple state, again,
even though he's got six years for.
Yes, go back for the voters,
essentially saying,
please be careful here. Right.
And it'd be interesting
for him to elaborate on what risks mean.
Like there
certainly could be a political risk
for Democrats here.
Perhaps not, because, again,
this is unprecedented.
It is an indictment
of a former president.
It comes at a time when Republicans
were already turning from the party.
But obviously you know,
just physical risk as well.
And hopefully,
you know, things remain calm.
And that remains the case.
And the key to that is we wait.
We wait that
it is, again, Donald Trump saying
he expects to be indicted
and arrested tomorrow.
We do not know that we will watch
the investigation play out.